Gaby, además de la escuela
tiene dos trabajos,
niñera y además trabaja
en la tienda de sus padres.
Trabajando en la tienda ella recibe un suelo
de 12 pesos por hora,
mientras que de niñera recibe solamente
9 pesos con 50 centavos por hora.
La semana pasada ella trabajó 19 horas en total,
esto me parece muy importante,
así que lo voy a poner con un color...
la semana pasada ella trabajó 19 horas en total...
de aquí va a salir una ecuación...
y esa semana se llevo 56 pesos más en la
tienda que en su trabajo de niñera,
esto también me parece muy importante.
¿Cuántas horas se dedicó a cada uno de
sus dos trabajos?
Y bueno, lo primero que hay que hacer cuando
tenemos un problema como estos,
es definir variables, así que primero
vamos a definir "t" subíndice "n".
"t" subíndice "n" es el tiempo
que ella le va a dedicar a ser niñera,
mientras que "t" subíndice "t" va a ser el tiempo que
ella  le va a dedicar a la tienda de sus padres.
"t" subíndice "n", "t" subíndice "t"
y lo que yo sé,
y fíjate bien, aquí voy a utilizar
esta primera oración que subrayé,
esta primera oración me dice que
en total trabajó 19 horas,
por lo tanto el tiempo que trabajó
siendo niñera,
más el tiempo
que trabajó en la tienda de sus padres,
esto en total
nos tiene que dar 19 horas.
Por lo tanto, "t" subíndice "t",
más "t" subíndice "n"
tiene que ser igual a 19.
Y bueno, ahora necesitamos otra ecuación,
y para sacar la otra ecuación,
voy a utilizar esta segunda oración que subraye
pero para esto lo que voy a necesitar,
es introducir dos nuevas variables,
voy a introducir el pago
que ella recibió siendo niñera,
le voy a llamar "p" subíndice "n",
es el pago que ella recibió siendo niñera,
durante toda la semana pasada,
es el pago total
que ella recibió siendo niñera
y también voy a definir la variable "p" subíndice "t",
que es el pago que ella recibió
trabajando en la tienda de sus padres,
esto durante toda la semana pasada,
el pago total.
¿Y por qué hago esto?
Porque date cuenta,
que esta segunda oración,
lo que me dice es que ella
ganó 56 pesos más en al tienda
que en su trabajo de niñera,
esto durante la semana pasada.
Por lo tanto,
lo que me está diciendo esta oración
es que el pago que recibió ella
en la tienda es igual,
a lo mismo que recibió siendo niñera,
es decir, "p" subíndice "n" más 56 pesos,
porque recibió ese mismo pago
más 56 pesos
y ahora ya tengo dos ecuaciones con cuatro incógnitas.
¡Oh no!
en que problema me estoy metiendo.
Fíjate bien, tenemos cuatro incógnitas,
dos tiempos y dos pagos,
mientras que tenemos dos ecuaciones,
¿cómo podemos resolver este problema?
Ahora, la forma de resolver este problema,
va a ser expresando los pagos,
cada uno de estos dos pagos totales
en relación al tiempo
en el que ella trabajó
en cada uno de sus dos trabajos.
Y de hecho,
es justo en este momento
dond e voy a utilizar cuánto ganó
en cada uno de sus trabajos por hora,
porque date cuenta, ahora sé que
la cantidad total que ella recibió
trabajando de niñera...
vamos a pensar primero en niñera.
La cantidad total que recibió Gaby
trabajando de niñera,
es exactamente igual al tiempo
que trabajó ella siendo niñera,
por lo que le pagan a ella
por hora siendo niñera.
Y si te das cuenta, a ella le pagan
9 pesos con 50 centavos siendo niñera,
entonces "p" subíndice "n"
es igual a "t" subíndice "n" por 9.50
Y va a funcionar justo igual
si nosotros pensamos,
en cuánto es
lo que recibió ella trabajando
en la tienda durante toda la semana,
"p" subíndice "t" es igual al tiempo
que trabajó Gaby en la tienda,
es decir "t" subíndice "t" por lo que
gana ella por hora en su trabajo en
la tienda, es decir, por 12.
Y fíjate que esto tiene toda la lógica del mundo,
porque si ella trabaja 3 horas en la tienda,
me quedaría 3 por 12
y entonces ella en total ganaría 36 pesos
y si ella trabaja 2 horas siendo niñera,
entonces sería 2 por 9.50 lo cual son 19 pesos.
Y estoy haciendo estas igualdades
porque ahora voy a sustituir
"p" subíndice "n" y "p" subíndice "t",
en esta ecuación que tengo aquí,
en lugar de poner "p" subíndice "n" y "p" subíndice "t",
lo que voy a hacer, es sustituir
lo que valen estas variables,
en términos del tiempo,
es decir, 9.50 por el tiempo
en lugar de "p" subíndice "n"
y por otra parte,
en lugar de "p" subíndice "t",
12 por el tiempo que
ella trabajó en la tienda.
¿Y entonces qué me va a quedar?
9.50 por "t" subíndice "n" más 56,
esto tiene que ser igual a "p" subíndice "t",
pero "p" subíndice "t" es lo mismo que
"t" subíndice "t" por 12,
es decir, 12 por "t" subíndice "t".
Y ahora si, ya tengo aquí dos ecuaciones
con solamente dos incógnitas
y logré tener un sistema de ecuaciones
con dos incógnitas
trabajando en esta sustitución  de estas variables
que tengo aquí a la derecha.
Y ahora si, si tengo dos incógnitas
y dos ecuaciones,
¿cómo resuelvo este sistema de ecuaciones?
Pues es momento de utilizar el álgebra,
tengo dos ecuaciones y dos incógnitas
y se me ocurre,
que de esta ecuación de aquí arriba,
lo que voy a hacer
es despejar alguna de las dos variables,
para utilizar el método de sustitución.
Y me queda que "t" subíndice "n",
más "t" subíndice "t" es igual a 19
y si yo resto "t" subíndice "t"
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
estos dos se van
y me queda que
"t" subíndice "n" es igual a
19 menos "t" subíndice "t".
Perfecto, ya tengo que "t" subíndice "n"
es igual a 19 menos "t" subíndice "t",
por lo tanto ya lo puedo sustituir aquí,
en lugar de poner "t" subíndice "n"
voy a poner 19 menos "t" subíndice "t",
es el método de sustitución,
solamente que con muchos subíndices.
Y bueno,
¿qué me va a quedar?
9.5 por "t" subíndice "n",
"t" subíndice "n"
es exactamente igual que
19 menos "t" subíndice "t".
Entonces me queda,
9.5 por 19 menos "t" subíndice "t", más 56,
esto tiene que ser igual a 12
que multiplica a "t" subíndice "t".
Y bueno, ahora hay que hacer 9.5 por 19,
9.5 por 19
lo voy a hacer aquí porque
realmente yo no me sé la respuesta de esta multiplicación,
así que vamos a hacerla a mano.
9.5 por 19
es lo mismo que 19 por 9.5,
5 por 9 es 45 y llevamos 4
y después 5 por 1 = 5,
más 4 son 9,
después pongo aquí un 0,
no lo olvidemos y me queda 9 por 9 = 81
y llevamos 8,
9 por 1 = 9 más 8 son 17.
Y ahora si, vamos sumar todo esto, aquí me
queda 5, aquí me queda 10, y llevamos 1,
aquí es 8 y este 1 se baja, entonces recorro
el punto decimal un lugar y me queda 180.5,
9.5 por 18 es 180.5 y después 9.5 por 1,
me queda -9.5 por "t" subíndice "t",
más 56, esto tiene que ser igual
a 12 "t" subíndice "t".
Muy bien, tenemos una ecuación con
solamente
una incógnita y entonces para resolver esto,
lo que voy a hacer primero es sumar 180.5 más 56,
lo cual me da 180, me queda 230...
236.5...
236.5 menos "9.5tt"...
menos 9.5 "t" subíndice "t",
esto tiene que ser igual a 12 "t" subíndice "t"...
"t" subíndice "t"...
Y ahora voy a sumar 9.5 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
para que este se vaya del otro lado,
entonces más 9.5 "t" subíndice "t"
y del otro lado más 9.5 "t" subíndice "t"...
más 9.5 "t" subíndice "t" y ahora si,
vamos a sumar esto y esto, de tal manera que
del lado izquierdo me queda solamente 236.5,
mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 12 más 9.5
y esto multiplicado por "t" subíndice "t",
esto es 21.5 "t" subíndice "t".
Y ahora, si divido todo entre 21.5,
voy a  encontrar el resultado
del tiempo en el que Gaby
trabaja en la tienda,
por lo tanto vamos a dividir todo entre 21.5,
todo entre 21.5
de tal manera que estos dos se van
y el tiempo en que Gaby trabaja en la tienda
es exactamente igual a 236.5 entre 21...
vamos a hacerlo también a mano...
21.5 va a dividir a 236.5...
236.5, recorremos el punto decimal un lugar,
entonces éste va para acá y por lo tanto,
éste también va para acá, y me queda 215
va a dividir a 2365,
entonces primero tomo esto de aquí,
me queda 1 vez,
aquí pongo 215 y voy a restar estos 2
y me queda,
6 menos 5 es 1,
6 menos 5...
sí, sí, sí... es 1 y después
3 menos 1 es 2,
entonces me queda 21,
aquí bajo un 5
y estos dos son iguales,
entonces ya la hice,
porque entonces pongo aquí un 1
y aquí me queda 215,
estos dos se van y se acabó...
¡Perfecto!
ya quedó,
ya sé que ella trabaja en la tienda 11 horas
y si trabaja en la tienda 11 horas,
¿cuántas horas va a trabajar
Gaby siendo niñera?
Pues bueno, date cuenta que aquí podemos sustituir
este valor y en lugar de "t" subíndice "t",
voy a poner 11 y me queda que el tiempo
que ella trabaja siendo niñera,
es 19 menos 11,
lo cual son 8 horas.
Ella trabaja siendo niñera 8 horas.
¡Y perfecto!
ambos tiempos suman 19 y tú puedes
verificar con calma la segunda ecuación.
Por el momento es todo,
nos vemos en el siguiente video.